shoving's conviction for second-degree
unintentional murder
second-degree manslaughter and third
degree murder
could land him up to 40 years in prison
jamie yukas is here in minneapolis as
you know she's been covering this trial
from day one
may i say doing an outstanding job james
joins us once again
you know you would think we had an
orange memo we did not we didn't we just
showed up like this
instead of fashion let's talk about the
verdict because jamie it came back so
quickly
i know it seemed like the jury was on a
mission didn't it yes
so based on the information that we had
from what we expected from court
schedules it appears that they worked
in really an extra hour on monday and
then they came in early yesterday they
also asked
no questions just got right down to
business
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
after only about 10 hours of
deliberation the jury found derek
chauvin
guilty of all charges in the killing of
george floyd
the ex-police officer showed no emotion
even as he was handcuffed and led
out of the courtroom and taken into
custody meanwhile
cheers erupted from the floyd family as
the verdict was read
the excitement turned into tears as the
relief sank in
i said i have faith that he will be
convicted
it's been a long journey george floyd's
brother philones gave
emotional testimony during the trial he
says this is only the beginning of the
fight for justice for his family
and other black americans who don't see
a guilty verdict
i'ma put up a fight every day because
i'm not just fighting for george anymore
i'm fighting for everybody around this
world and justice to the floyds means
change change that only comes from the
very top
i think if john is coming my dad is
going to change the world he's going to
start to change it now
president biden called floyd's family
after the verdict was read
and later addressed the nation with vice
president harris
they advocated for the george floyd
justice and policing act
which would ban chokeholds and qualified
immunity for officers
the president and i will continue to
urge the senate
to pass this legislation not as a
panacea
for every problem but as a start
this work is long overdue
nothing can ever bring their brother
their father
back but this can be a giant step
forward in the march
toward justice in america minnesota
attorney general keith ellison says
the victory his prosecutor secured is
only a ripple in what needs to be a
title wave of change
i would not call today's verdict justice
however
because justice implies true restoration
but it is accountability
which is the first step towards justice
we have to march
we will have to do this for life
we have to protest because it seems like
this is a
never-ending cycle
chauvin will be sentenced in about eight
weeks the other three
officers involved in george floyd's
fatal arrest are set to go to trial in
august for aiding and abetting
second-degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter charges
i also want to mention that darnell
frazier the teenager who captured that
cell phone video that was
so critical to this trial posted her
reaction to the verdict
on her social media page saying quote
gail george floyd we did it
justice has been served of course her
testimony very important as well for
testimony her videotape we're all very
thankful to darnell frazier because we
would not be here if it was not for
darnell frazier
but can we talk about sentencing for a
second uh
some of the charges carry up to 40 years
as the second degree charge
what does that really mean in terms of
sentencing about what he could actually
get
well it's interesting because under
minnesota's sentencing guidelines of
course the second degree is
murder charge is 40 years it drops
though to 12 and a half because he
doesn't have any other prior convictions
however there's upward sentencing
departure is what
prosecutors are going to ask the judge
for which could increase it we're told i
talked to some attorneys last night who
said
he could get 30 years because he not
only in their mind
abused his authority which they will
argue but also committed these crimes in
front of
minors of course that's why the
prosecution brought that nine-year-old
up on the stand many people wondering
why would you put a nine-year-old
through
testimony this specifically was probably
the prosecutor's
reason why so that they could ask for
more time i see so is it clearly up to
the judge
it is solely up to the judge uh and that
was the defendant's choice that's derek
chopin's choice
he could have had the jury decide that
but it's now in the hands of
judge peter cahill and let's talk about
the jury for a second about the
deliberations
do we do you know who the jury foreman
was and how that happened
so we got the information of course all
the jurors
filled out questionnaires before they
became jurors so juror number 19 was a
30 year old white male
and apparently he was picked to be the
foreman and he's the one who then gave
the verdict to the judge all right jamie
thank you